vous subissez l'ablation des testicules
ça dure 2h j'ai une opération assez
assez bénigne c'est rien du tout c'est
une petite opération mais c'est dans la
tête que ça se passe
si vous n'êtes pas préparé pour ce genre
de choses il faut pas le faire
et nous accueillons notre invité du
samedi 20h ce soir Henri Monot bonsoir
alors Henri mono
vous avez 65 ans vous êtes retraités
vous avez une vie de famille épanouie et
vous êtes un authentique survivant
pendant plus de 20 ans vous avez lutter
contre des bouffées de libido qui
rendait votre quotidien invivable alors
vous avez décidé de vous faire castrer
pas chimiquement mais physiquement et
aujourd'hui tout va bien
mieux que ça
je suis totalement épanoui très heureux
[Musique]
Henri monore vous êtes né le 12 mai 1946
à Lausanne en Suisse père militaire de
carrière mère femme au foyer alors c'est
un enfant espiègle turbulent un
adolescent parfois difficile votre père
vous envoie en Allemagne pour vous
recadrer
ça va pas très bien réussi comme vous le
remarquez mais enfin ça quand même eu
l'avantage me permet d'apprendre
l'allemand ce qui est extrêmement
important dans un pays comme la Suisse
où on est obligé quand même d'être mis
voir trilan voilà alors à 23 ans après
votre service militaire vous faites
l'école d'hôtellerie de Lausanne vous
devenez directeur d'un hôtel de la ville
à 24 ans vous vous mariez avec une fille
que vous connaissiez depuis 10 ans deux
ans plus tard de un enfant et deux ans
après un autre voilà alors pour ce qui
est de l'intimité de votre couple à
l'époque vous avez une vie sexuelle bien
remplie mais pas débordante il y avait
déjà une forte demande mais enfin qui
restait dans des limites parfaitement
raisonnables voilà alors sur le plan
professionnel après une expérience aux
Etats-Unis vous revenez en Suisse et là
vous faites comme votre père vous entrez
dans l'armée vous devez 32 ans et vous
deviendrez général
oui c'était pas prévu du tout
m'a proposé de rester quelques temps
dans l'armée je suis resté 27 ans et
c'est vrai que j'ai fait du général de
brigade c'est bien là vous observez que
votre sexualité prend une place
grandissante dans votre couple alors
évidemment vous essayez des nouvelles
choses des nouvelles positions etc vous
pensez simplement à l'époque que votre
sexualité celle de votre femme est en
train de s'épanouir c'est exactement ça
alors avec le temps ce que vous preniez
pour du désir se transforme en véritable
bouffée de libido vous dites c'est comme
si en m'injectait de la testostérone
dans le cerveau c'est comme une espèce
de demande d'éjaculation à tout prix
quoi alors c'est exactement ça vous
tombe dessus d'un coup d'un seul vous
attendez pas du tout et c'est un besoin
absolu de sexualité irrépressible
irrépressible irrépressible il faut par
un moyen ou un autre calmer ce besoin ça
peut être la douche froide ça peut être
la MAS
alors résultat effectivement vous
comblez votre épouse mais en plus
effectivement vous masturber plusieurs
fois par jour le problème c'est que
c'est débordements de sexualité commence
à devenir de plus en plus difficile à
gérer parce que vous avez carrément des
crises une fois vous êtes en voiture
vous êtes obligé de vous arrêter pour
pour vous soulager disons c'est vrai ou
j'ai dû m'arrêter sur une autoroute on
va ce que on ne peut on peut plus gérer
c'est pas possible c'est ça qu'il faut
comprendre c'est quelque chose
d'infernal avec le temps pareil lorsque
vous êtes en réunion avec d'autres
militaires vous êtes obligé de vous
voilà de vous isoler un petit peu
exactement donc sous n'importe quel
prétexte fallacieux inévitablement on
sort un moment on revient ou alors on
reste dans son coin complètement isolé
les gens vous pose la question mais tu
suis ce qu'on dit tu sais vous êtes
ailleurs alors là évidemment vous
commencez à considérer votre libido non
plus comme un plaisir mais comme une
souffrance vous vivez dans une angoisse
permanente de débordement et vous mettez
en place des stratagèmes par exemple
lorsque vous êtes seul dans un bureau
avec une femme vous laissez la porte
ouverte parce que vous craignez le
regard des autres donc vous dites si on
peut nous voir ça va me ça va prévenir
ce geste quoi oui quand on est conscient
de ce genre d'addiction vous faites en
sorte qu'il ne puisse rien vous arriver
donc c'est vrai qu'un quand
un petit une petite discussion avec une
dame ou
je sais pas on laisse la porte ouverte
on fait en sorte que ne puisse rien
arriver
en plus dans son esprit on a
inévitablement avec le temps
l'impression que les autres peuvent
penser quelque chose alors on fait en
sorte que ça se passe pas oui le pire
c'est l'idée que ça puisse se voir sur
votre visage en fait vous avez peur
d'être démasqué c'est vivez sans arrêt
dans cette hantise et dans cette honte
au moment de dire mais c'est pas normal
et tout ce qui m'arrive c'est pas
possible il faut absolument que ça
change il faut absolument que je me sors
de cette affaire on est toujours plus
fort que les autres on veut le faire
tout seul et puis ça marche pas alors là
vous essayez le whisky alors évidemment
ça vous calme ça vous endort mais en
fait ça ne fait que repousser l'échéance
parce que quand vous vous réveillez
c'est encore pire quoi quand vous
réveillez le lendemain
alors vous regrettez tout de suite ce
que vous avez fait c'est totalement vous
vous faites du mal et encore bien plus
de mal
et puis un soir l'effet de l'alcool
s'avère plus désinhibant que calmant
vous discutez avec une jeune femme
lorsque vous voyez de la peur dans ses
yeux il y a eu ce moment où il a fallu
dire STOP ouais et c'était parfaitement
clair que la certainement aider à dire
stop je l'ai compris à cette histoire
votre médecin vous dit le problème il
est dans votre tête allez voir un psy et
le psy vous dit non le problème il est
pas dans votre tête je me sentais pas du
tout avoir besoin d'un psychiatre je
l'ai fait ce psychiatre que j'ai été
voir a été à Monsieur extraordinaire à
tout de suite compris que c'était pas du
tout ça il m'a énormément aidé et c'est
certainement grâce à lui que on a pu
arranger les choses voilà au fil des
rendez-vous finirez par trouver le nom
du mal dont vous souffrez c'est un
dysfonctionnement hormonaux émotionnel
voilà là vous racontez tout à votre
épouse vous dites un moment terrible
mais elle a compris elle était
remarquable elle a parfaitement compris
aussi certaines choses à un moment donné
qu'elle comprenait peut-être pas très
bien avant
elle m'a énormément aidé et ça ça a été
vraiment
un chemin à deux
alors là vous commencez un traitement
avec un médicament c'est une sorte de
castration chimique mais les effets
secondaires sont très difficiles à
supporter vous avez des crises de
frilosité effectivement je me rappelle
très bien en Italie un soir il faisait
une température énorme et j'étais
enroulé dans une couette et pendant deux
heures de temps j'ai tapé des dents
tellement j'avais froid et en même temps
je transpirais énormément évidemment
soit des situations qui sont rémund
désagréables et puis alors ça vous
déprime c'était pas ta dépression
c'était des crises de déprime tout à
coup ça vous prend comme ça aussi vous
essayez dans un corps pleurer deux
heures
alors ça m'a coupé ma libido ça m'a
permis si vous voulez de revenir
ce que j'appelais moi normal ne plus
avoir de sexualité parce que ça me fait
tellement souffrir et puis d'un autre
côté
vous avez des étudier vous étiez pas
plus heureux qu'avant finalement j'étais
plus heureux parce que je n'avais plus
de souffrance venant de la sexualité
mais j'étais malheureux parce que je
savais pas comment m'en sortir du tout
est-ce que je continue avec les
médicaments je souffre plus de la
sexualité mais je souffle d'autres
choses qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire il y a
un moment donné c'est difficile mais là
il y a une solution c'est la castration
physique c'est la castration
définitive le 21 septembre 2004
vous entrez dans une clinique de
Lausanne et vous subissez l'ablation des
testicules ça dure deux heures j'ai une
opération assez
bénigne
que ça se passe
si vous n'êtes pas préparé pour ce genre
de choses il faut pas le faire si vous
êtes pas persuadé que c'est bien il faut
pas le faire quand vous êtes allé faire
cette opération donc est un qui est
faite par des gens qui qui opère des
transsexuels etc est-ce que vous vous
aviez peur d'y aller non non pas du tout
pas du tout écoutez la clinique m'a
annoncé que j'avais une place pour
l'opération au mois de juin pour le 21
septembre et depuis ce moment là j'ai
compté les jours
j'ai compté les jours et chaque jour me
dit c'est la sortie du tunnel avance
alors c'était plus possible aujourd'hui
vous n'avez plus de vie sexuelle alors
du tout pas du tout du tout strictement
aucune vous dites en fait le sexe m'a
tellement pourri la vie pendant les
années que ça me manque pas du tout
finalement mais je suis ravi quand vous
avez souffert et souffert et que vous
avez votre vie qui a été mené par des
glandes il y a qu'une solution c'est de
vous en séparer être heureux ça c'est
fait je suis très heureux alors votre
épouse vous dites elle m'a aimé hyper
sexuelle elle continue à m'aimer sans
sexualité c'est sympa
c'est plus que sympa elle vous aime je
pense alors aujourd'hui
finalement le dysfonctionnement
hormonaux émotionnel peut pousser à à
commettre vous le savez des choses
irréparables est-ce qu'on peut se
contrôler finalement
incontestablement il peut et on doit se
contrôler et voyez-vous ça dépend quand
même énormément de l'éducation que vous
avez reçue vous aviez un permis
militaire
probablement probablement et une mère
qui a été très aimante mais très strict
aussi ils ont bien fait grâce à cette
éducation grâce à la société dans
laquelle j'ai grandi et je me suis
épanoui ça m'a probablement
empêcher de
d'avoir peut-être des accros disons
mentales vous pensez qu'à un moment vous
seriez sauté sur une sur une fille quoi
probablement si j'avais pas eu la chance
d'avoir justement ce bagage qu'il
fallait pour pas le faire et j'ai eu
beaucoup d'énergie pour pour résister
en fait ce qui a vécu ce monsieur c'est
un peu empire ou avec une sorte de
paroxysme ce qu'on a tous un peu vécu
dans certaines périodes de nos vies
c'est ça qui est terrible c'est un peu
un peu la tragédie des hommes moi je
suis désolé de me citer comme ça mais
c'est vrai que dans un roman récent
dernier la très grande amont je vais
écrire une phrase qui je trouve qu'ils
résume bien tous là les hommes c'est
l'homme c'est le seul animal de la
création qui a sa queue devant et qui
court après
je suis maintenant persuadé que si
on consulte
dès qu'on se rend compte qu'il y a
quelque chose qui se passe pas bien moi
c'était vers 40-45 ans je dirais là je
pense qu'il y a de fortes chances de
s'en sortir parfaitement bien mais il y
a un moment donné on attend on attend on
attend on est plus fort que les autres
on est meilleurs que les autres on va
s'en sortir tout seul il y a le fameux
tabou de la sexualité on n'ose pas
c'est à vous qu'il faut casser dans
notre société ça prouve qu'on peut
parfois
commettre des actes répréhensible et
être malade quoi mais bien sûr mais ce
que je trouve extraordinaire dans ce
qu'il dit c'est
la façon dont son éducation
lui permet de contrôler cette pulsion
tellement insupportable qu'elle va
l'amener à la castration mais il y
arrive parce que ça devrait nous faire
réfléchir ça quand même tu vois
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu